welcome to this video bunga bunga bunga
bunga German German flag at least yeah d
3 against the French so oh he's actually
no he doesn't know his stuff is this any
fair Bishop g5 okay yeah there's someone
we had time of Kings Indian attack and
Bishop g5 is a tricky move I think
actually quite an interesting choice for
wine how do you play that now with black
is it Tom t5 he might take and play ed
ed D Phi it looks like looks rather ugly
and e5 also looks ugly yeah but I really
don't know what to do besides that to
try to keep stuff closed that that is
actually good news and that he was not
playing C 3 and d for this son would
have been a little bit more worrisome my
belief okay let's just trade this this
thing on d5 yeah okay I'm glad that he's
got a pawn dano not some pundits in
peace okay so do i play night at five
and take his bishop off I mean in case
of a non yeah okay he's doing something
concrete but this is not really not
really dangerous right let's do that
Queen g7 I don't think is that much of a
problem here and now i can take and
install this fantastic knight on d4
this is what you want ok so that's
that's a great position now with this in
itm but how to continue maybe Queen to
b4 yes yeah let's let's trade the
Queen's for a good end game yeah
interesting I cannot play five well
maybe I can but I are not really not
really ok ok I'm going to take it why
not to get them get the King involved
rook a one that's night see two I guess
I was thinking about the move but I
thought I can take rook takes 90 choice
rather embarrassing yeah I don't I
wanted to play a five anyway so I don't
mind that our no rookie idea I'd help it
he only has opened the e-file for me I
guess the knight on d4 you cannot attack
at the moment with any rock or what
whatever piece will be three rupee one
or gautam let's enter I guess I cannot
do without the eponymous I want to move
my a look at some point what now I have
a broken one route be one rookie wanna
like full infiltration maybe I get the
beep on possible it's actually not that
easy for why to act to make to make a
useful move here it's really tied down a
bit huh if i take it not really yeah
there is a look-see for I am okay i
guess i have to take it and repent king
d6 look-see for King d5 just grab it
he's not in a position to to give any
checks at the moment maybe with the King
rules there is this look on the third
it's not even on yeah like King g3
that's rookie three check yeah look III
check and it didn't really help him much
check
yes Knight f3 isn't this like dangerous
check group KX loop takes Bishop g2 whea
what a shame but it's got this check
here ok let's let's check it again do
all that and then Bishop g2 we are
amazing there's some other way to to
play this ok and now the rook is
attacked and I'm threatening Knight f3
check key on the third and 92 check this
should be should be quite good I didn't
see that one that's not good
it's it's the only defense but of course
of course sufficient hmm
which which means I only have two pawns
for the exchange no time morning
it's really a matter of those pawns
getting to roll I get in like be 59 to
your phone and that's all very nice but
do I manage King here 94 king deform eye
candy for it's not a thread so because
of night be three so i can i can
actually move the porn okay well this is
now okay the rook is really bad on a
three yeah yeah that's good no my my
whole position is in harmony in a way
yeah i just takes you three now theme I
don't see ya this is possible no I'm
getting the other other thing rolling
okay h5 was may be dangerous maybe Eric
everyone now not gotten check
hmm yeah that was bad technical play by
black check check now I want to I want
to still try to win the game maybe maybe
a silly idea
ja couldn't manage really check game
today oh man cha I'm coming I was coming
from a complete win 22 this and and then
again to win and then asking did I
forget oh wow why am I not winning here
I don't get it really what is my mistake
I went here yeah probably am Knight f6
25 I actually saw the idea but it yeah I
thought that just get the porn ruling
and at age 5 is this is the real issue
probably he have it this again he just
his just in time to get this counter
play and I was trying to still win yeah
maybe there was something actually it's
the wind probably F to win so this also
winds up so that not he 3 takes night
night III is winning okay yeah because
he cannot cope him before him and then
it means yet he basically has no news
now I'm getting getting both pawns
through okay yeah many chances missed in
this game many chances but in fact the
yeah i mean this this is like like a
tough time to not win this is the
easiest yeah just just do it like that
getting to this rook endgame that's the
easiest yeah that's the easiest way to
do it you cannot go here because of the
check that's a purely technical win not
not any tactics tricks what not yeah not
a good game simply thanks for watching